last year for the first time ever the
public got a glimpse into the financials
of airline frequent flyer programs
what they saw was truly astonishing
during the early days of the covet 19
pandemic airlines were hemorrhaging
money and so naturally they looked for a
loan
united for example sought 5 billion to
tie the company over until travel came
back but like with any loan they needed
to put up collateral they needed to
offer something to the bank that it
would acquire if the company failed to
pay the loan back
the problem was united wasn't worth much
at the time since of course it was
hemorrhaging money meaning it would have
had to offer a huge chunk of itself as
collateral rather they decided to offer
one of their subsidiaries as collateral
mileageplus holdings llc essentially
their loyalty program
of course given that united is a
publicly traded company they have
various financial reporting requirements
including the obligation to file a form
8k with the securities and exchange
commission whenever a major business
event takes place such as taking out a
multi-billion dollar loan of thousands
one line on this document stood out
quote multiplying mileageplus holdings
2019 ebitda by a factor of 12 equates to
a mileage plus valuation of
approximately 21.9 billion dollars 21.9
billion dollars that's the value of
united's loyalty program according to
the company and this loan similar
financial disclosures from delta and
american airlines pegged the value of
their loyalty programs at 26 billion and
and a half to 31.5 billion dollars
respectively
so not withstanding their size why did
these numbers turn heads
well because of these the airlines is
market caps these figures equal the
total value of all the shares in each
company it's essentially a real-time
indicator of what wall street considers
a company worth given the ebbs and flows
in stock prices at the time united's was
10 billion dollars delta's 20 billion
dollars and americans 6 billion dollars
so the value of each airline is less
than the value of their loyalty programs
which is interesting in and of itself
but the airlines own their loyalty
programs therefore at least according to
wall street airlines themselves
are worthless in fact they're more than
worthless they have negative value
they're lost leaders and the only thing
imparting each airline with value is its
loyalty program
this is a less absurd proposition than
it might initially seem in 2018 well
before the covet-induced travel downturn
american airlines earned about 14.42
in passenger revenue per seat per mile
flown but simultaneously it cost them
14.85 cents to operate a given seat one
mile so the airline actually lost about
half a cent for each mile it flew each
seat
the company however earned 1.9 billion
dollars in pre-tax profits thanks
exclusively to their 4.2 billion dollars
in frequent flyer program revenue in the
u.s airports are plastered with ads for
co-branded airline credit cards touting
free checked bags and other benefits
they're stuffed with lounges accessible
to frequent flyers but not even first
class passengers they're littered with
priority lanes reserved for getting
elite status members through security
and onto planes more quickly airlines
even have their flight attendants acting
as salespeople reciting credit card
pitches at 30 000 feet in exchange for
the chance of a commission on a
passenger sign up the reason why the
entire flying process in the u.s and
increasingly other countries seems like
a carefully manicured experience nudging
you to sign up for credit cards and
frequent flyer programs is because of
these numbers airlines are hardly
transportation companies anymore over
the past 40 years they have crafted a
system so effective so unbelievably
advantageous to their own interests that
they are now willing to lose money
flying to prop up their frequent flyer
businesses businesses whose core
proposition is giving away free flights
today airlines are basically banks
this all snowballed from a concept no
different than the loyalty punch card at
your favorite sandwich place you fly a
certain number of times you get a free
flight while airlines had already
started tracking the activity of
individual flyers formal frequent flyer
programs became technically and legally
possible with the deregulation of the
american airline industry in 1978. the
first program was set up by a small
airline called texas international which
later merged with continental but the
first major long-haul airline to do so
was american airlines in 1981. what the
airline observed was not surprising
american advantage members were more
likely to choose to fly with american so
that they could accumulate enough miles
to get a free flight in fact they were
even willing to pay slightly more some
five percent extra for an american
flight rather than an equivalent united
flight for example since that united
flight wouldn't get them any closer to a
free american flight it's all sunk cost
fallacy if someone's earned 10 000
advantage miles they'd prefer to fly
american and get to the 12 and a half
thousandth for free flights rather than
starting from zero with united even if
they'd earn the same number of miles
overall the program certainly did have
an expense for the airline but it
quickly became clear that the expense
was far eclipsed by the additional
revenue it brought in but more
significant that the program's launch
was its first evolution beyond the
sandwich shop punch card in 1982
american partnered with hertz and
holland america to allow its members to
earn points when renting cars or booking
cruises but the concept of earning
points with partners was not what was
revolutionary about this rather it was
the behind-the-scenes mechanics that
made that possible american wasn't going
to give miles away for free when people
spent money at another company because
the redemption of miles did have a cost
for the airline beyond small variable
costs like food fuel insurance and more
there is potentially significant
opportunity cost from offering a seat in
exchange for points if that seat might
have otherwise been booked by a paying
passenger therefore america needed to be
compensated for the miles he gave to
hertz and holland america and so for the
first time it put a real monetary price
on its imaginary points while the actual
numbers are closely guarded secrets
american airlines would for example sell
one point to hertz for one cent which
hertz would then reward to its customers
in order to incentivize them to rent at
hertz rather than another rental car
company that did not reward airline
points now if hertz paid that one cent
per mile which is within the range of
educated estimates and if a customer
redeemed 25 000 miles for domestic
flight which was a typical redemption
rate at the time that means american
would have earned 250 dollars for a
domestic flight considering the typical
variable cost for a domestic flight was
about 15
american airlines quickly recognized
just how incredible the profit
opportunities could be they started to
realize them in 1987 when american
teamed up with citibank to offer a
co-branded credit card
that way for every dollar spent on the
card the member would earn a point
this dramatically increased the volume
at which american and other airlines
sold points to external partners and
shifted these programs from ways to
incentivize more spending on airfare to
profit centers in and of themselves
today part of the strength of these
multi-billion dollar programs is based
on the fact that despite their strength
government and businesses essentially
treat them the same as that sandwich
shop punch card to start with almost
universally points are not taxed despite
the fact that one can accumulate points
like income and redeem them for
something worth money governments
consider it a rebate or cash back on
your purchase because to get that reward
you had to spend money and you can't
exchange that reward for money at least
officially just as you don't pay tax on
the amount saved when bananas are 25 off
at the grocery store you don't pay tax
when the airline awards you points you
can use for free flights in this case
the savings just happened further away
from purchase however unlike with
sandwich punch cards or banana discounts
in this case the people paying for the
flights are often different than those
receiving the reward almost all of
airline's most frequent flyers travel on
business in which case their employers
pay the airfare despite that frequent
flyer programs award points to the
individual flying not the individual
paying in addition if the employee books
the trip on their company card they also
get the credit card points from that
spend the companies paying don't really
have a problem with this because it
essentially acts as a free tax free
benefit for their employees business
travel isn't anywhere as glamorous as it
used to be so companies are happy to
allow their employees to earn points
they can eventually use for leisure
travel in exchange for them getting out
on the road and making money of course
this potentially creates a scenario in
which the individual is incentivized to
fly or pay more on the company's dime
but most don't seem too worried about
this
so both tax law and company policy or
the lack of it works in favor of the
airline the way in which frequent flyer
programs were set up wasn't perfect
though there was potential for exploits
namely as airline revenue management
systems became more complex price and
travel distance became less and less
correlated nowadays it's rather
intuitive to us that the 400 mile flight
from dc to nantucket a high-end vacation
destination is going to cost more than
the 400-mile flight from dc to boston in
fact american's lowest price for that
nantucket flight is 98
while its flights to boston start at
just 49
so it's double the price for the same
distance simply because the more wealthy
travelers headed to nantucket are more
likely to pay for the convenience of a
non-stop flight meanwhile based on the
traditional one mile one point system
the member would still gain just 400
points for each of those flights despite
the difference in price therefore if
someone found an itinerary that was low
cost but long distance their mileage
earning could be so high that the miles
earned would be worth more than the cost
of the flights for example if one found
an itinerary from los angeles to san
francisco via chicago the traveler would
earn 10 times the point than if they
flew direct and more complex revenue
management systems would likely price
that long circuitous connecting
itinerary lower than the non-stop one
since it was less convenient all around
this was bad for airlines it was
incentivizing people to take longer
multi-stop itineraries which cost the
airline more to operate and it forced
them to give out more miles which cost
the airline more in redemptions in short
they were incentivizing against their
own interests this was a rare element of
the system that did not work in their
favor
so they changed it over the past decade
nearly every major program has pivoted
to a system where passengers are
rewarded points based on how many
dollars they spend rather than how many
miles they fly among the big three
american airlines it's simple you spend
one dollar you earn five points this
shifted the system from one where the
airline wins overall but might lose out
from time to time to one where the
airline quite literally cannot lose at
least on the earnings side revenue based
systems cannot be exploited but airlines
quickly figured out how to restructure
the redemption side in their favor too
it used to be that any economy class
flight within the continental us cost 12
and a half thousand points on united
regardless of whether it was a tuesday
in february or the sunday after
thanksgiving that's despite the fact
that cash rates were undoubtedly far
higher on the sunday after thanksgiving
one of the highest demand travel days of
the year while availability of point
seats differed that meant that someone
who did manage to score thanksgiving
sunday booking on points got a deal the
cost for the airline to offer that seat
on points was greater than what the
airline earned that's since the
opportunity cost on those highest demand
days is huge as almost every available
seat is likely to be sold for cash even
if it all worked out in the end in the
airline's favor they didn't like these
losses so they switched the way
redemptions works too
now nearly every major airline has
dynamic award charts
just like how cash fares rise for high
demand days so too do point redemption
rates for example in october 2022 united
is charging 114 dollars for non-stop
newark to denver flights on low demand
tuesdays and 254 on high demand sundays
meanwhile mile redemption rates rise
from 8
300 to 22 200 points
that roughly two and a half times rise
for each means that mile rates are now
correlated to cash rates and so
arbitrage between what airlines charge
in miles and cash is no longer possible
so they've now closed loopholes on both
ends of the equation you can't exploit
the accumulation of miles or the
redemption of miles essentially the only
factor placing a check on airlines is
power is the exchange rate considering
how much of their profit comes from
selling points to credit card companies
and other marketing partners airlines do
care tremendously about how much those
companies are willing to pay for points
and how much those companies are willing
to pay is loosely based on what the
general public believes those points are
worth
various travel and finance websites
publish their estimated point valuations
to help inform consumers of whether
they're getting a good deal with a given
redemption and there is a good amount of
variability aggregating 5 estimates the
average value of 1 point is 1.218 cents
for delta sky miles 1.226 for united
mileage plus and 1.416 for american
advantage what this means is that if all
else were to be equal consumers would be
more incentivized to fly american
flights use american co-branded credit
cards transfer points to american and
more which means credit card companies
and other marketing partners are likely
to run out of american points sooner and
need to buy more that being said power
is still in the hands of airlines as
there are only three major long-haul
airlines in the u.s but far more credit
card companies united has partnered with
chase american with citibank and delta
with american express but if any of
these credit card companies refused to
agree to a higher mile purchase price
when contract negotiations came around
the airline could dump them and switch
to bank of america barclay capital one
discover each of which would be
delighted to score a major airline
partner
so why is it that the value of these
frequent flyer programs has eclipsed the
value of the airlines themselves well
it's because what's happening here is
that airlines are essentially acting as
the central banks for their own virtual
currencies they're acting like the us
treasury or the bank of england or the
european central bank and that they
control the supply of their currency but
airlines power actually goes far beyond
that of these central banks not only do
they control the flow of the currency
but they also control the availability
of goods to spend it on then on top of
that it's as if these all-powerful
central banks are operating as private
for-profit companies that can just
create more of their currency for the
purposes of selling it at any given time
airlines have nearly complete unchecked
control over a currency with which they
are the only entity that can convert it
to cash
that is the key to their power
frequent flyer programs are genius
financial instruments because it's
nearly impossible for airlines to lose
alright so think about all the times in
your day when you're not using your ears
maybe while you get ready for the day
make dinner do laundry or drive to work
all that time you could be entertaining
and educating yourself by listening to
audible audible is the place to get
spoken word entertainment they have a
massive streaming catalog of podcasts
audiobooks guided fitness sleep tracks
and so much more then on top of that for
anything not already included you get
one credit per month you can use to get
any audiobook in their premium library
which includes pretty much every major
title for example i recently listened to
the ride of a lifetime which is a memoir
retelling bob iger's rise from low-level
production assistant at abc to legendary
disney ceo especially focusing on the
two-decade process of developing
shanghai disneyland i absolutely love
listening to audiobooks on audible and
if you don't already i think you will
right now for a limited time you can
save 60 on your first three months of
audible that's only 5.95 a month so give
yourself the gift of audible by clicking
the button on screen heading to
audible.comwendover
or texting wendover to 500 500.